bene a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fan di j
oggi andiamo avanti con slater di harry
vol eravamo rimasti che praticamente la
nuova entrati st galleria e abbiamo
scoperto che oltre allo slider c'è
diciamo un suo amico sempre stupratore
che veramente molto ma molto più
inquietante dello slider stesso è una
cosa veramente assurda raga nel primo
episodio mi sono veramente spaventato a
morte
c'era da veramente non ho parole per il
primo episodio è stato veramente una
cosa assurda aim ok kate debutta più le
foto ei skansi i'm going to fail ha
indotto fi non si capisce un cazzo a
come scrive anche il to find you saw you
can see inizio più rivol kate
ok 7 penso sia al voto io per la
scrittura ti darei due ma non fa niente
andiamo avanti lei primo episodio avevo
capito che per proseguire devo attivare
sto sto ascensore diciamo ad arrivare in
cima alla torre per farlo devo attivare
se i generatori quelle spie devono
diventare tutte verdi è questo e primo
ok ragazzi siamo uno su sei
se a pezzi sono aperte tutte le porte e
da adesso inizia il divertimento per voi
egli infatti iniziano per me grazie
ragazzi vi voglio veramente bene in
questi momenti vi vorrei abbracciare
tutti perché siete voi a consigliarmi
questi giochi quindi grazie
non mi ricordo nell'ultima puntata che
strada avevo preso ok c'è un generatore
che non avevo attivato l'ultima volta
quella scalinata è stata traumatica
ok ci siamo secondo generato è attivato
ragazzi mi sento carico stavolta so già
che finirò male ma non importa che c'è
una strada di sotto anche qui
ok direi di entrare qui dentro non c'è
niente draga ho veramente paura che
salti fuori di nuovo quel pezzo di merda
perfetto andiamo andiamo piano piano
casa ok ok ok come non detto
entra entra e 333 prezzo ok ok ok piano
piano a non entrare perché ci sono gli
stupratori anche delle gallerie
oddio stupratori everywhere è una cosa
assurda ragas del gioco maledizione che
cazzo cazzo quanto sei bello veramente
ho trovato la ragazza giusta per te ho
giocato un gioco di recente si chiama
the grudge c'è una bella [ __ ] che ti
farebbe veramente comodo comunque direi
di proseguire che cazzo è veramente
inquietante sa fare cioè non so neanche
dove va tra l'altro io vado avanti non
può prendermi più di un tot di volte
perché come abbiamo visto nello scorso
episodio se mi prende un tot di volte
alla fine muoio quindi devo cercare di
scappare più possibile ma oltre al fatto
che cesto deficiente di merda c'è anche
lo slider c'è sono in due ragano ne
basta uno ci sono due super attori in un
videogame
veramente ovviamente due stupratori
meglio che one anche stavolta è comunque
vabbè andiamo avanti spero di non
incontrarlo in giro perché veramente una
cosa assurda non dirmi che sono ben
seppur eastwood lander che faccio due
passi non posso ricorrere vi ritorna lo
pesa anche il lander non c'è verso non
c'è proprio verso cazzo eh no non cosa
no addio carri buttati giù dalle scale
cazzo ok con ricarica ricarica rigori
maledizione corri corri maledetto
stronzo veramente una ragazza non
importa tu corri deve entrare a qualche
parte deve entrare da qualche parte
dentro mai che fate le vostre qualche
parte tra qui dentro e torni dei tre
yacht a un cesso che si chiuda un cesso
che si chiuda agli authority chiodi che
porca [ __ ] porca [ __ ] lo sapevo
aiuto ma perché che cazzo 3 su 6 raga io
non ce la farò mai prima che mi prenda
minchia che ansia la gamma si può
c'è veramente non so neanche dove cazzo
andata a finire non c'è più è sparito
perché questo effetto sonoro di merda
che mi mette un asse della madonna
vabbè lasciamo perdere andiamo avanti
praga è il gioco più
non lo so è gioco che mi mette più
tensione di sempre
oddio oddio no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no
no no no no che cazzo ma perché io gioco
sta roba perché ma perché io anche speso
3 dollari per comprare st fare cazzo ma
non a caso pure rose lander [ __ ]
possibile perché io gioco a sta roba
perché chi è che me lo fa fare chi è che
mi ha detto fa vj gioca stander chi e
voglio incontrarti chi è che me l'ha
detto voglio incontrarti voglio
stringerti la mano ma forte te la voglio
stringere cazzo è stata veramente una
cosa assurda io dovevo fifa non ce la
farò mai raga è troppo difficile
vabbè senza che non facciamoci domande
ci manca veramente solo questo
andiamo a stavolta va da un'altra parte
ma fronte uccisioni nelle gambe
ok
inquietante di prima fantastico bene di
qua non c'era ancora stato ovviamente
perché ovviamente dovremo entrare in
questi posti io
va beh noi entriamo lo stesso voglio
darmi una calmata perché veramente ho
gridato peggio di non so che cosa ma
veramente una cosa assurda
siamo a due noi abbiamo incontrato
ancora nessun e spero che rimanga così
la situazione non posso salire sulle
scatole no vero ok no perché non so
quanto le scatole possano proteggermi in
teoria ma non importa
ok non sta incontrando nessuno è un
miracolo è veramente un miracolo
devo trovare altri due ma tra l'altro
posso c'è ci sono generatori di fuori
perché non lo so io finora sono stato
dentro che cazzo è quando sono rotelle
perfetto speriamo che non arrivi adesso
perché non saprei come scappare perfetto
siamo a tre
siamo arrivati a quanto eravamo prima
soltanto che adesso non ha posto ancora
nessuno sa chi è non è apparso ancora
nessuno incredibile
ok ok come non detto come non detto
perché io parlo porca [ __ ] devo stare
zitto devo tapparmi la bocca cazzo
perché quando parlo
parlo succedono cose che non devono
succedere che cazzo ma che cazzo è
successo ma sono morto subito
ma no ma prima mi doveva stuprare tre
volte adesso mi ha superato una volta
sole sono morto perché c'è una zona
nuova raga non l'avevo ancora vista c'è
indica il terreno cosa devo fare
mettermi a scavare è ok
non c'è nessuno perfetto trovate un
altro generatore qui non ce l'ho proprio
neanche mai stato
o forse sì sì no ce lo stato mi aveva
anche stuprato qui non lo ricordo non è
che posso aprire le porte novero non
posso neanche nascondermi cazzo non
posso nascondermi che cazzo ed era man
no sono connetti fantastico non so dove
andare
perché non ho capito sinceramente come
faccio a superare quel tipo perché
che cazzo era che cazzo è stato
cazzo cazzo corri lo sapevo era dietro
di me lo sapevo lo sapevo
maledizione devo nascondermi forse se
faccio lo slalom non mi segue non lo so
però devo muovere il culo lo stesso devo
muovere il culo lo stesso anche se ha
funzionato perché la vedo brutta è ok
qui siamo all'entrata perfetto dobbiamo
entrare a qualche parte muoviamoci
ok ok butteri cazzo con ricordi con
ricordi c'è un altro generatore certo
generatore carri cazzo ok ok ok ok ok ok
siamo a 3 solo a te cazzo non ci posso
credere
come faccio a essere solo a tre mi
sembrava di essere a 20 ok deve entrare
in una stanza qualsiasi questo non so se
va bene non so se c'è l'europa dove
posso nascondermi si sa se ce la posso
fare
ce la posso fare se c'è una bottiglia
d'acqua non ci ho paura risala brutto
stronzo pervertito ok
effettivamente non sta entrando ti fa
paura la bottiglia d'acqua e brutto
stronzo è andata via la musica ragazze
la sto facendo non ci credo oh cazzo no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no kay se n'è andato raga devo
approfittarne corro non è ancora passo
lo slider tra l'altro esso che ci penso
cioè soltanto come non detto
ma perché cazzo io parlo perché perché
ditemi perché datemi un motivo datemi un
cazzo di motivo del perché io parlo
quando non devo perché lo sa dove dov'è
andato aiuto no no no no no no
no no ed un generatore vedo la luce
rossa non devo correre perché mi
superano la prima occasione
devo riuscire a correre quando ne ho
bisogno che siamo a quattro ragazzi sto
avvicinando alla fine sta diventato
ovviamente penso che diventi sempre più
di 16 anni una [ __ ]
siamo a 5 non ci posso credere chiudi st
portano in merda chiuditi no spegne la
luce
mettiti in un angolo ok calmi siamo a 5
record assoluto
ok non mi ha preso neanche una volta
perché sono riuscito a sfuggirgli i modi
veramente impensabili come non detto
come non detto chiude cure di chi gli
chiede chi gli chiede ti prego ti prego
ti prego accendono sempre il cielo
adesso vado a giocare con bambini all
oratorio anche se mezzanotte non importa
ma basta che te ne vai ti prego dimmi
che te ne vai
ok se n'è andato se n'è andata se n'è
andato è un deficiente fortunatamente
era fatto a tal punto da non vedermi
anche se gli ero di fianco raga devo
uscire però veramente paura ho veramente
paura che spunti qualcuno
ok ragazzi sono ci sono non ci posso
credere
6 su 6 6 su 6 devo tornare no no no no
adesso no adesso no kat
no non posso morire ancora non posso
morire ora no dopo tutto sto casino non
posso morire
devo aiuto alla stanza ci sono c'è lo
stupratore merda come faccia dove
l'ascensore dove dove aiutarli e liquori
brutto stronzo e qui dai dai dai dai dai
dai dai dai dai no no no no non ci credo
mica grazia dai accendi si no alzati
piuttosto jazzati brutto stronzo dove di
questo lo vedi non lo vedi perché sono
troppo in alto [ __ ] che cazzo di
ansia mamma mia ci ho messo un secolo
raga ce l'ho fatta
non si può raga non avete idea di quanto
ci ho messo ho fatto un taglio assurdo
perché è riuscito una roba di due ore
madonna santissima che ansia che ansia
perché mi consigliate questi giochi
perché perché raga perché guardate non
sono contento cazzo sono contento adesso
dovremmo fare l'episodio successivo che
questo qui che abbiamo fatto si chiamava
to die bis e adesso ci sarà il prossimo
episodio ma ovviamente non lo faccio in
questo video ma lo farò nel prossimo
come al solito se il video vi è piaciuto
lasciate un commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come ogni video
trovate nella descrizione se non si
attaccò di siti iscrivetevi noi ci
vediamo al prossimo video bella ragazzi